hello and welcome to Playstation grenade
I know what you're thinking where the
hell have I been for the last three
weeks where are the map updates well
they've been a bit slow but this week it
is a monumental week so many updates to
get through so you know the drill
sit back for 10 minutes slap code atom
arrow in the font night shop and let's
break down the recent updates to
fortnight chapter 2 without a doubt the
most important update is the new snowy
map I know what you're thinking snow way
well yes way it feels all Christmassy
unless unless you're in Australia of
course but this year the snow doesn't
cover the entire map and the husks and
fiends which ruin lashya are thankfully
not here either so you pee this time we
have a partially covered map rolling
through the mountains and the higher
areas the first thing I had to check is
Graham the genome at the radio station
in the north of the island Graham has
always watched over us and now the snow
has hit will he still be here yeah
thanks for all your hard work Graham
you're the best genome ever
[Music]
okay I'll be serious I'm sorry let's
start with the snow update the biggest
thing comes over at the docks where one
of the warehouses has changed completely
this place is now an ice factory and the
detail is staggering the ice blocks the
machinery this is a hefty update which
looks fantastic and could confirm the
return of frozen rivers and lakes later
in the season whilst here though noticed
that the ice bins are searchable and
inside I found coal and guess what it's
a throwable weapon here in fortnight
just like in real life sorry YouTube I
am not telling people to throw coal at
each other my apologies
in-game the damage isn't great but we do
this for the memes I also found the
snowball launcher here confirming that
mayhem is here for the festive season
the former updates the docks has now
gone there are no more reindeer llama
here which means they must be somewhere
else on the island well we didn't have
to look far just up the road north to
retail row the snow has covered this
area as it's so close to the mountain
range there isn't the Christmas tree in
the main cordoned area just yet but one
update has arrived
the seasonal shop has opened its doors
inside we have the first Christmas trees
of the year and presents to ransack two
extra points for the llama tapas genius
work and yes those llama that we
couldn't find at the docks are in here
now I got to admit I do love this store
update the standard out of use version
then became the Halloween edition and
now it's the Christmas themed shop it
just worked doesn't it GG devs whilst
here I found the Snowman item it's back
once again it's still ridiculous but it
wouldn't be Christmas without it here's
a snowman sitting on a chair looks like
he's got issues it's officially
Christmas now then the Christmas update
though has changed things slightly check
out what happens when you destroy one of
the snow dudes it becomes a boulder of
ice we can launch it at friends and
enemies in a
into damage it also forces the ice feet
to mechanic in a way slide around so I
wondered if it was possible to play the
Olympic spot of curling with chairs and
hell yes it is so dis God family I call
out to you guys let's play this sometime
let's play fortnight curling with chairs
if you have the amount anyway the winner
will get the last minute epic Xcode I
have as we are so close to the bunker
before we leave this area we should do
this each week I sit down and think
about the importance of the bunker and
this week it's a huge week have you ever
looked at the ego logo in depth well
rotate that bug around and look it's an
image of this very bunker this place
really is the most important spot on the
island I have the story theory to go
here but but as this week's update is so
huge I'll wait until after the Star Wars
event to upload it but it's worth it I
promise
mob on can watch next week
[Music]
speaking of star wars though the event
this Saturday take a look at risky reels
right now the Star Wars celebrations are
almost complete but look at this what
the heck could this mean we have four
plants facing a large central stage
could we be voting for something or
maybe four characters will appear here I
can't wait to find out this Saturday if
I had to guess I'd say there will be
presenters on the smaller stages and
maybe art from the movie or a scene from
the movie on the huge circle projector
man I'm so hyped here's a question for
you do you like Star Wars and has
fortnight's involvement in that
franchise made you less or more hyped
for me I am definitely so much more
hyped but let's quickly backtrack here
and see what actually happened too risky
over the last week or two well over a
month ago the first signs were present
check this out
when gliding in four weeks ago the
demolition vehicles were already here
did you spot it well look again yeah the
magnetic truck thing was there all along
hidden in plain sight until we got too
close this was followed up with screen
tests at risky and if you were lucky
enough you got to see the llama screen
but things then escalated seven days ago
the trucks moved in beginning to move
all the vehicles this is because in
fortnight vehicles don't do anything
they don't move they just stay
completely still maybe one day they will
function but at the minute they're just
decorational so over the next four days
the cleanup continued with the camper
vans and cars all being shifted out of
the way
and look at it now I also love how the
light can be seen from anywhere on the
island so epic if you've been living
under a rock
check out the Star Wars posters around
the island for your time zone of the
event fellow stormtroopers I look
forward to sharing this experience with
you see you on Saturday depending when
you played this week something else
happened here did you see this I wasn't
there to see it but my friend manchild
yes that does his name is called
manchild said these clips over a live
test of the microphones can be heard
testing one two three
testing one two three his wild cut 278
experience of the sort of mini test
event by the sounds of it four different
mic checks were there
and it was also possible to spot these
four characters testing emotes character
load times and other live events
shenanigans for certain this will feed
into this weekend Star Wars event but I
found this so cool that the tests were
made in completely open public service
GG if you manage to see this
with all this good stuff going down we
should really jump back in time about
three weeks ago there was a small change
to the island but we haven't covered it
in this series we will now journey week
7 signs were added around the map to
help traffic get their bearings we have
the farm the suburbs a swampland and
even the beach gets a nod everyone loves
the beach even in winter I think that's
because we're all sons of beaches sorry
sorry I don't know why I do these things
I can't help myself sometimes
anyway whilst I was searching for these
this week a brand new location popped up
just outside misty Meadows and as a side
point misty actually looks just like a p
Hamlet now oh so beautiful before I get
sidetracked by chapter one from
nostalgia up in the mountains is a
chalet but this place is a dance haven
in the snow
take a look inside we have a central bar
with seating and a dance floor but
there's also room for a DJ possibly to
play some terrible Christmas music which
we all love Oh hate I love to hate you
get you get the idea and there's also a
VIP section just for me and you don't
tell anyone else here's something quite
interesting to add to this no in
playground we have these portals to
quickly navigate around the island but
look at them more closely each of them
has snow which isn't in the game right
now so this almost certainly confirms
that more snow will be arriving as the
season continues so if you are dreaming
of a white Christmas you may get one in
a digital sense
[Music]
and yet another location has popped up
in the snow
check out this palace hidden away in the
mountains is a hotel completely made of
ice these exist in real life by the way
- it looks like it's advertising a new
bundle all ice themed but as a new
location this looks so good so you
definitely need to check it out it's
just next to the bunker if you are
interested at all potentially something
horrible is going to happen just like in
season 7 or is it season 6 where the ice
block made its way towards the island if
you look around the island right now
it's possible to spot one or two of
these let's hope that it's not bringing
those husks again I'm getting PTSD just
thinking about it we will see what
happens could that bring the rest of the
snow to the island we shall see
and one last smash of nostalgia for all
you og players remember granny's house
from season 7 of chapter 1 well it's
back and it's beautiful the house can be
found south of the farm and round the
Crimbo tree is potentially three
chesticles to get your hands on it's
secluded - so this actually may be a
great landing area for non sweats let me
know if you try it please
and to end all this depending on your
game mode and the platform you are on
it's possible to spot aurora borealis in
the sky the Northern Lights nice a very
nice touch
so there we have it week nine everything
you need to know about it what a good
week this is of course I will miss
something so please let me know if you
spot something that I didn't my DMS are
always open and my twitter is at Adam
granade as always here's the legends
roll call for those people who are
lovely enough to use my code Adam are
you in the fortnight shop if you don't
see your name please keep in mind I
can't tell who uses my coat that's why I
keep my DMS open so you can tweet me
some proof and get in a video oh and
also the rules of the Creator code have
changed so here's more transparency when
you use code a tomorrow to buy something
I get a tiny proportion of the money
from the sale it isn't much but if lots
of people use it it adds up so if you
see the hashtag epic part it means that
okie-dokie everyday is a school day
thanks for your time if you've made it
this far let's do something weird what's
the most ridiculous spotlight crossover
you can think of
I'll go first fortnight cross Teenage
Mutant Ninja Turtles damn it I would buy
off her skins if that happened I'm so
sad I'm Adam from Playstation grenade
you're awesome
remember that have a good Christmas I'll
see you soon
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]